oh look at that
you look just like each other
britney spears and her fiance sam asgari
joke they've already welcomed a baby
together it's fun for me on monday the
39 year old pop star and her 27 year old
leading man had a little fun on sam's
insta story posting this clip of britt
playing with a baby doll along with the
caption quote exclusive we had a baby
what should we name her
oh look at that
you look just like each other
and all that baby talk kept rolling into
the next slide he's talented got that
choreography down she's a natural like
her mama she's a natural like you
of course the pop star returned to
instagram last week after tweeting that
you would be taking a little break to
celebrate their engagement
sam popped the question on september
12th and shared the news on instagram
look at that
you like it yeah
and while the couple was clearly joking
around with their baby doll brit did
discuss her desire to have a real baby
when she testified in a june
conservatorship hearing of course
brittany is already a mom to two sons
sixteen-year-old shawn preston and
fifteen-year-old jaden james whom she
shares with her ex kevin federline i
love being a mom i would love to have
more kids
brittany's conservatorship has been a
hot topic of discussion on friday
controlling britney spears was released
on fx and hulu it's the follow-up doc to
the new york times presents framing
britney spears which dropped earlier
this year
her manager said don't get too close
people have a way of disappearing
on sunday cnn also released a
documentary about brittany titled toxic
britney spears's battle for freedom
which explored her struggle to end her
legal conservatorship and now a third
documentary is out on netflix brittany
versus spears
brittany had a fear that her family
would barge in and take everything on
monday the lucky singer slammed a recent
documentary she watched about herself
but she didn't specify which one posting
this video posing in a white crop top
and shorts alongside a caption that read
in part quote it's really crazy guys i
watched a little bit of the last
documentary and i hate to inform you but
a lot of what you heard is not true
[Music]